I think the fire-crotch dating started
way before in the Lindsay Lohan time
ever since I guess I hit puberty hi my
name is AJ and I'm a redhead this week
I'm gonna go blonde my color red like
it's slightly different from the average
Irish redhead cuz I'm actually not even
Irish at all and I'm the only one with
red hair both of my siblings have dark
brown hair dark brown eyes but my mom
has red hair I feel like I used to find
ginger offensive but actually call
myself king of the gingers when I was
asked about dyeing my hair I said no I
personally would never die my hair I
think redheads are unicorn it seems like
such a cool unique thing that not a lot
of people get I've always been nervous
about getting back to the original color
I guess being a redhead is definitely a
huge part of my identity definitely been
told throughout my life but not to ever
dye my hair
I don't think redheads should dye their
hair any color every time I go to a
hairdresser they complement my red hair
they try so hard to get this same exact
color but they always tell me how
unsuccessful they are for my friends you
already know me is gonna come off as a
real shock because they do love my red
hair I get attention as is with red hair
but I think going blonde I'm gonna get
even more attention my name is Gigi hair
stylist today we do the highlights my
feelings towards my red hair has
definitely changed in the beginning I
didn't really think much about it as I
got into high school I was probably the
only one with red hair I definitely was
picked on for being a redhead they would
call me hair top fire-crotch
all of the above and then we do the
dominant color at the same time so we
didn't off take the cutter
I think women with red hair are
glorified within society opposed to men
who are kind of looked at or have the
stereotype of being nerdy geeky there
are a million women leading actress
roles with red hair the men red-headed
roles are always the best friend or the
geek here in LA I don't think I really
know of any other redheads I haven't
dated a redhead before but I've
definitely fooled around with one
took about two hours from beginning to
end eager to see what I look like
alright now you left your ring oh my god
Wow I look like a completely different
person I think I'm giving off that I'm
now California beach vibe you look
Tanner a little bit actually looks great
I do like it I it's definitely different
it's gonna take a little bit to get used
to I think I will be perceived
differently by people who don't know me
also have my friends too so now that I'm
blonde I'm going to live the rest of the
week and see how everybody reacts to me
and see if it's any different from being
a ginger saw myself slightly freaked out
seeing that I didn't know who that was I
did tell a couple of my co-workers
they've only known me as a redhead we
shall see how people react today I've
had some interesting interactions with
people who had previously known me there
have been a lot of Game of Thrones
references usually Targaryen and Ken
doll references as well from co-workers
and clients there's also been a lot of
you look great
except I prefer you as a redhead I
believe dinners never dye their hair go
back page a personally I almost feel
like I'm wearing a mask being blonde
because I've been red my entire life and
it's almost like I'm not even being true
to myself I slightly must be in a red
head I had somebody at the gym actually
comment and say I am one of six redheads
that actually come and now I'm literally
just like everybody else there so
something else that I noticed is
whenever I run into another redhead I
wait for some sort of acknowledgment I
was in the grocery store probably looks
kind of creepy staring at this person
still waiting for some sort of
acknowledgment even just eye contact and
I had forgotten that I dyed my hair
blonde and just kind of came off as a
creep I guess so I'm about to call my
dad
hello and add AJ you don't like me
blonde I don't know you're sharper
before I found myself actually taking my
shirt off during my workout class today
which I have never done before I walked
into work this morning and one of my
instructors first thing that came out of
his mouth you look so much more
approachable what did I look like when I
had red hair so as I talk a little bit
more to my friends about being blonde
opposed to being a redhead I've noticed
that although we're thought of as fiery
or temperamental
we're apparently the least shy of the
hair colors which I don't know if I
completely agree with that because
growing up I definitely was a lot more
shy until I got comfortable in my own
skin here in Los Angeles I do feel about
being a redhead I stand out a little bit
more right now I kind of feel like I
blend in when I walk down the street I
don't know if I feel like I would
actually go blonde again I mean I like
it I enjoy it but I do feel like this is
hiding my identity a little bit thena
ginger is so far into Who I am I can't
see myself going any other way maybe
blonde highlights every now and then
[Music]